للمرة السابعة البرلمان اللبناني
يفشل في انتخاب رئيس للجمهورية.
عن لقاء الاسد واردوغان على
اراضيها مجددا ومن ارضية التفاوض
لكن السؤال هل هناك مرة ثامنة
بوتين يظهر الاسلحة المدمرة تلو
هذا الاجراء سيزيد من غضب كوريا
الشمالية وذلك بعد مساعي سيول
الولايات المتحدة التركية على
الوقف الفوري للتصعيد التركي
اسرائيليا غير معتاد بين بلدين
من المفترض ان بينهما اتفاقية
تركيا لحربها. هذا العثماني لن
يقف بعد اليوم وسيسلك جميع الطرق
اعلنت الحكومة الصينية ان حصيلة
الاصابة اليومية بفيروس كورونا
صحيفة بلومبرج. فيا لكم من
ماكرين هؤلاء. بينما تايوان
من امريكا. شركة تكنولوجية
تايوانية توقف اعمالها مع ايران
اتفق الضابط مع الصين بالاستسلام
فورا في حال اندلاع الحرب بين
الاخر، فلماذا كل هذا الاستعراض
من الجانب الروسي؟ هل هناك مخطط
بكين الى اكبر معضلة شهدتها
الصين في السنوات الاخيرة حيث
سيكون قاحلا لديهم? نترك الاجابة
لكم. وعلى الخط الساخن الرئيس
الامريكي مات وولش يهاجم الغرب
بسبب الحملة الغربية على قطر.
واستهدف اقليم كردستان العراق.
فماذا لو حصل تصادم مع الطرف
عالقين في مصر بعد لهم الاجواء
المصرية والله وعملوها الرجالة.
سلام منذ سنوات طويلة. مضيفة ان
الطيارين الاسرائيليين لا يزالون
يحصن حدوده الشمالية لوقف
الانتهاكات الايرانية التركية
حيث اعلنت الدفاع العراقي انها
تعيد نشر قواتها على طول الحدود
التركي او الايراني. الاحداث
والتطورات. قناة كان حتشوت
نسخة من مفاتيح كيم النووية ويجب
الا تزعجوها يا هؤلاء هنا شقيقة
اجهضنا ستين مليون طفل وحولنا
الاولاد الى فتيات. اليوتيوبر
مع ايران وتركيا وذلك بعد القصف
المتكرر الذي نفذته الجارتان
ليكشف وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصيا
كار ان تركيا قد نفذت هجمتها على
لفرض عقوبات على بيونج يانج بسبب
اطلاقها المتكرر للصواريخ
في الاونة الاخيرة في شمال سوريا
هددت سلامة العسكريين امريكيين
الحاضرة والسابقة وينشر قواته في
الشريط الحدودي. نعم. العراق
هناك وان الوضع المتصاعد ينبئ
بحرب قد تطول لسنوات لتحض
ليقولها. لقد حان وقت المحاسبة
ليجهز جيش العراقي فواتيره
الاوساط. فلتفكر قليلا باكل
الخراف والدجاجية هؤلاء ولتترك
الى ارضية الحروب. البنتاجون
يصرح ان الضربات الجوية التركية
سنوات ولم يتم نشر الاحصائية
خوفا من انتشار الرعب في
والتي بلغت رقما غير مسبوق منذ
بدأ الفيروس بالتفشي قبل ثلاث
حد اقصى للاسعار ليخرج المستشار
الالماني هولاف شولز ويعلن ان
الطاقة الاوكرانية الى انقاض فهو
يستخدم الشتاء كسلاح حد تعبيرها.
زعيم كوريا الشمالية توجه رسائل
تحذيرية للجارة الجنوبية قائلة
الكلاب للحراسة. شقيقة المجنون.
تفقد اعصابها. نعم. هي تمتلك
العظيمة حيث دشن الرئيس الروسي
الكاسحة النووية ياقوتيا هي
الاسرائيلية الحدث الذي وقع في
مصر بطرد القاهرة لاحد عشر طيارا
الاستراتيجية والهامة الى الصين
وذلك مقابل رشوة مالية ضخمة. حيث
العالم يوزع الاستخبارات الصينية
تغضب الجميع. اصحاب العيون
للعودة الى واجهة العالم. هنا
وبرغم النفي التركي روسيا تتحدث
مكالمة مزيفة لروسي نجح في تقمص
شخصية الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
الحساب. العراق يتحضر عسكريا
لمواجهة ايران وتركيا والغربيون
اكثر من خمسمائة هدف وذلك ردا
على عملية تفجير اسطنبول
الباليستية فماذا لو غضبت هذه
المرأة ما الذي ستفعله يا ترى?
على البنية للطاقة بينما قال
عمدة كييف ان سبعين في المائة من
الامريكان والالمان بالغاز وهم
من صدعوا رؤوسنا بان الشتاء
يعترفون ويعتذرون لقطر واحد عشر
طيارا اسرائيليا يطلبون النجدة
وجهاتها الشرعية. نعم فالسرقة
والسوق السوداء حاضرة قوة لهذه
كاسحة جليد شاملة المهام تعمل
بالطاقة النووية هي كيلواء عصية
البلدين الذين يشهدان توترا
سياسيا وعسكريا متصاعدا والمصدر
تايوان تحقيقا مع ضابطها الذي
كان ينقل الملفات الاستخبارية
شولز منذ عام مضى كانت مرافق
تخزين الطاقة لدينا فارغة اليوم
بلاده من الطاقة خلال الشتاء بل
هناك صفقة من تحت الطاولة والصين
تصريحهم لتخرج وكالة رويترز
بتقارير عن لعب الامارات دور
الخزانة الامريكية تعلن انها لن
تستورد النفط الروسي حتى بعد وضع
الاسلحة وذلك حسب تصريحهم. هنا
جنود الظلام نقصد الاستخبارات
البولندي اندريه دودا يقع في
الفخ الروسي حيث انتشرت مؤخرا
ماكرون ناقش قضايا امنية مع رئيس
بولندا اندريه دودا. ولم يعلم
للاستخبارات الاوكرانية على خط
انابيب غاز السيل الجنوبي حسب
هي ممتلئة بشكل كامل. المانيا لا
تتحدث بل تعمل. لكن كيف اكتفى
الضيقة يختارون اسهل الطرق
للوصول لاهدافهم. هنا فتحت
الغرب واوكرانيا. فهل حان وقت
الحسم؟ هجمات كثيفة ومرعبة
ان انطلت عليه الحيلة الروسية
وكما يقولها رؤوف خليف في كأس
البولندي يقع في فخ ماكرون.
الاسلحة الامريكية لا تصل
عبر لقاء جمع الروس والاوكران
على الطاولة الاماراتية. وزارة
بعد مخاوف من التورط في تصدير
معدات للحرس الثوري. ومن قوة
دودا بالامر الا بعد سبع دقائق
هناك اغلق سماعة الهاتف لكن بعد
امن الطاقة لهذا الشتاء بات
مضمونا. فكيف ذلك يا هذا? يجيب
الوسيط في اتفاق جديد لتبادل
الاسرى بين اوكرانيا وروسيا وذلك
الروسية اذ اعلنت ان الامن
الروسي احبط هجوما ارهابيا
التصعيد التركي في سوريا
واردوغان يعلنها لقد حان وقت
تستعد بالعدة والعتاد بانتظار
ساعة الصفر. وفي مجاملة للتقرب
تتدخل. الاشخاص في بكين يتساقطون
والارقام تزداد بشكل جنوني
سفيرة الولايات المتحدة تصرح ان
بوتين مصمم على تحويل منشآت
القوة والهدف شق ممرات مائية في
القطب الشمالي لدعم حركة التجارة
وبعد انسحاب روسيا من خرسون
اوكرانيا تقاتل الروس في الجزر
والمستنقعات لتحرير جزيرة ليأتي
الكرملين لكييف بالحل بامكان
العالمي. بينما نشرت وسائل اعلام
امريكية. تقريرا قالت فيه ان
للبنى التحتية للطاقة الاوكرانية
بسبعة وستين صاروخا. ليخرج
عن فالروس ينفذون برنامجا ضخما
لبناء كاسحات جليد نووية فائقة
الروس على لسان الجيش الاوكراني.
القوات الروسية قصفت مواقع عدة
للمطالب الروسية. فهل يقبلون ومن
الحلول البسيطة الى حلول بوتين
العاصمة الاوكرانية محرومة من
الكهرباء بسبب القصف الروسي.
قادة اوكرانيا انهاء معاناة
الشعب الاوكراني عبر الاستجابة
زرنسكي مناشدا الامم المتحدة
بشأن هذا الهجوم الروسي المتواصل
الروس حسم المعارك على الارض سبب
كثافة الدعم الغربي وجدت موسكو
حلا اخر لا يحتاج لكثرة الجنود
وبضربات صاروخية عن بعد يعلنها
فما الذي يحدث? روسيا تعطي
اوكرانيا الحل. عندما لم يستطع
تسرق الصندوق الاسود الخاصة
بتايوان والاستخبارات الامريكية
ثلاثين في المائة فقط من الاسلحة
المرسلة لاوكرانيا تصل الى
في وجه كوريا الجنوبية وواشنطن
حياة جنودنا في خطر. لوقف
ومنظمة الصحة العالمية تتدخل
لتدارك الموقف. شقيقة كيم تصرخ
للاوكران. فمن يأخذها اذا؟
مستشار المانيا يعلن اكتفاء
وزلنسكي يستنجد والكرملين ياتي
للاوكرانيين بالحل. والرئيس
يجول في ذهن الدب الروسي؟
لنريكم جديدنا. تعالوا ولا
تخافوا. نعم سلاح روسي جديد يرعب